whoa I need a kill [ __ ] you throw a
grenade at me bro
wait so good days at me why are you
teasing me
hold on the early I said I was gonna
throw a gurney right I know I said I'll
jump over dead
[Music]
alrighty guys so I'm happy out of my
house right now and I'm putting over to
Sacramento California to go hang out at
the air and Fox and check out his battle
station my name is doug sester Marty I'm
a professional gamer and a four-time
Call of Duty champion when I'm gaming at
home this is my battle station where I
play I'm looking forward to getting to
Sacramento to see what Fox's looks like
all right guys I got about literally two
minutes to get to my gaming D Aaron Fox
is the starting point guard for the
Sacramento Kings Baron pops can he do it
one more time and he's also a big-time
gamer that's why I'm here in Sacramento
to talk about video games basketball and
get a good look at his battle station yo
what's up man it's got the air and how
you doing man appreciate you coming I'm
doing great
yo this place is sick and I appreciate
it just got it actually you have an
awesome house you show me around man
yeah yeah no problem man we walk off so
who's the best gamer in the league that
you you're the best gamer in the league
depending on what what are we playing
what games Call of Duty owe me for sure
you're the best Call of Duty player in
the NBA and I even play you're claiming
right now on camera this is official
that you are the best NBA player that
was called the Yvonne the best players
force to be honest like basketball
football baseball soccer I think so I
would love to challenge you through a
game of Call of Duty to see oh I don't
know I think I think I get a kill you
think you'll get one kill good luck
you'll get one kill oh these get you're
like one be one [ __ ] you got something
like that for sure I'm gonna trap you
you will not even be able to move I'm
gonna get a kill cuz you're gonna miss a
shot at some point I think you have a
better chance of scoring a basket on you
in basketball than you have on getting a
kill on me in Call of Duty not and I
know how like I know the level in NBA
and like I'm an amateur for sure I'm a
good acute OT playing a 10 I believe so
five bucks for sure we definitely we got
to do the Bucks name I can hold my own
[Applause]
so here we are
Wow man I got a little bit of help with
this oh so like I would usually watch TV
on this I just watch sports whenever I
love these lights I'm going purple the
purple the posters McDonald's
all-american hey we put on that goal
this one over here yeah we put on that
one you know five bucks I make this
ready what are we working with so over
here this is we know setup my bro this
is me right here both of our games are
using setup monies and then we have
computer setup when these do these
things recline like any like they were
fine and then you take the pillow off
you see a fox this is my last name is
Fox and it's thought to be a cool little
thing and green is my favorite color
that's why I sit in the green chair
so I'm sorry man I was just dozing off
for a second cuz I just know how easy
this one's gonna be man that's crazy I'm
gonna just use this controller right
here I guess this little piece of Provo
he's already at an advantage so I don't
have like I don't have my normal
controller I'm just gonna use this one
and just clean him up real quick the
Aaron's gonna use this matte black one
right here I'm going with the scuff this
is good I like the pattern on it too
that's cool and you like the four
paddles on the back too yeah I like the
four you put the tube I used to yeah
played before all right so you got your
scuff gaming controller you have your
HyperX headset what about your PC down
here also my PC was actually made by
GeForce they did everything this is an
actual screen that's cool you can see
inside of it this is a pretty good setup
I love how you have the two desks and
they're kind of connected with these
wires and these lights that you put out
man they're pretty movin I love the
lights
I love the computer the controller I
don't like obviously actually I'm gonna
tell you the reason that I have both of
these on my desk usually is because I
still have friends that like playing GTA
so with this you can't play a racing
game because you're always gonna be
going too fast you got to hold it all
the way down and you can't because of
this no so like you press it and it's
basically the equivalent to holding this
all the way down well that's why I have
this so when I play that like you can
ease it alright what class you're gonna
use I'm just go with the can this is
solid the hybrid mags and a grip okay
I'm using the Mattox man I got Maddox
with this also co-player don't need this
that will keep the lightweight you know
what not let's use dexterity recourse
yeah no stunts just gone we'll get a
coast on the straight gun yeah alright
cool I'm just checking all my settings
real quick
okay I'm good right we got default
controllers black ops for 1v1 first ten
kills five dollars online let's do it
let's do it this is weird bro there's
low I have not used a scuf controller
there you go
by the suture oh I need a kill he
doesn't even care about the win he does
nothing it won't kill that's it I'm
supposed to win underdog mentality what
was your first game you play when you
were a kid it was like a fishing game
some fishing wait you're talking about
bass fishing is that bad yeah bad that's
the sega game from back in the day i
don't understand why i love that game
cuz i don't fish I've never fished a day
in my life
and maybe because it was like out of the
norm out of the ordinary for me but like
I love that game what was the game that
made you turn into a gamer cod for for
sure like bro I didn't even have my own
place yeah me too me and my brother
shared a ps3 it went up so what temper
sneezes yep to go his own cross yeah so
I like got his got his thing up to the
gold cross hit me with your best right
now I'd see if I could block it let's go
oh go ahead oh dude this is split screen
is not it bro you have a much faster
time I have a Mattox but 10 is really
good too though yes
I'm not losing this game underdog
mentality it's not I got vibration on on
this thing - hold on a second I like
playing with the vibrations do you game
every single day you gain my twice a
week probably too much you game every
day what every single day like cuz even
on the road I I have the Asus monitor
games portable no I don't so I look I
don't like the little the carry box
juju has that yeah is it's against I
tried it I guess it's too bulky I don't
I feel you me so I used it it's they
have like a little travel monitor that
you can that you can take so I use that
I always have my ps4 with me but I
usually play games that I don't do so
like I don't play together that often so
I'll play like mad and you have see you
get tired of it from playing all day and
like actually playing basketball so you
don't want to come home from practice
and then see a virtual ball bouncing
when you're gaming what type of snacks
you go to like cheat steps yeah I love
things like what is that hockey's people
got me on this in high school like at my
high school
everybody this is Annie leaps net it
looks like Austin Dillon or something
man I don't even want to know I'm just
gonna try it it's great I just got up
indulge me if I have a go-to snack this
is it don't you throw a grenade at me
bro why are you doing me all right you
put up you believe in me bro I've
literally and getting so mad right now
it's four four dude you're actually
making this really close so your setup
is pretty dope man is there anything
else you would want to add into it or is
it complete I think I have enough
screens TVs like everything I think is
perfect
you know what I word and if I was you
man boy a decent controller would you
rather have your son follow your
footsteps with basketball or gaming I
would say basketball I know I wouldn't
force it upon him but like he's gonna be
around the game so much that he wanted
the basketball ace I think it'd be cool
to have like you've seen it like a
father and a son both making it to the
NBA and I would I would say basketball
for sure that's a great mindset to have
man but if he's five six you gonna have
to hop on those sticks
yes son here's a gaming controller for
sure I like that that's good that's a
tough way that was a tough question
though so who do you like to a game with
most on your team
yogi plays a lot of black out but I
don't play black out I don't think
anybody else on the team actually games
like that so I'm gonna go with a former
teammate Justin Jackson do you play with
a lot of players in the league
oh no I'm not really because guys like
Ben and Kat they play uh they come on PC
they play a PC you know they play they
usually play they used to play Club G
though but Kat does have a ps4 he does
play Cod I play with Dennis every once
in a while I didn't Smith yeah no no
since high school
I probably said I play with Dennis and
Justin the most you hold up hold up time
guys he doesn't want to die he's out
getting point we went around here did
you got eight kills we're a plain old
thing you were a master prestige man
this is hard but obviously you didn't
have your controller so it's kind of
automatically gonna say that I'm taking
the L for this and I got a moral victory
right here this is a moral victory
what's the $5.00 at I three hours dude
well-deserved money man go buy stuff
something nice I'm gonna go get a bag of
takis you got a sick pad you got a sick
battle station and before we go there's
just one last thing I want you to do all
right this is space invaders I know this
is way before your time but I played
this a little bit I just want to know if
you to beat my high score okay post
player one
I think you're gonna that's it okay Oh
what am i shooting at you guys shoot at
these alien things cuz they've time to
destroy your six-year-old but how do you
become good at this only shot you we got
to realize we got you
so that's it man
I'm not playing that again
I'm Doug Sampson Martin thanks so much
for watching battle stations
make sure you guys subscribe to the
bleacher report channel to watch more